speaking of racism and you're quite
right the
democrats are really pulling out the
race card now because donald trump
improved the percentage of black vote
from 8 to 12 from 2016 to 2020
that's a 50 increase and they are scared
to death
in 27 gallup did a poll
obama's running for the nomination
against hillary and
uh mitt romney's running for the
nomination on the republican side
against john mccain
what percentage of americans gallup
asked would not vote for somebody who's
black five percent
what percentage would not vote for
somebody who's a woman eleven percent
what percentage would not vote for
somebody who's a mormon 24 percent
what percentage would not vote for
somebody who would be 72 when he became
president
and that'd be john mccain 42 so obama
had a lower hurdle than these what three
white politicians what are we talking
about here
grow up knock it off
it's like the average person especially
during lockdowns i would go to a lot of
the rallies to open up the state and i
was meeting
you know people that own restaurants and
people that own businesses that they
were not political they certainly were
not republicans
but they were mugged basically mugged by
reality and they were going i just want
to go to work
i have a feeling a lot of them can be
broken and they can move
to say the conservative side or
republican or larry elder thing but
what do you think is do you think
there's something else you got to do to
get them to make that final jump
well that's why i need the money i need
to be on television california is a big
big big state and you need to be on tv
you need to be on radio
but dave it doesn't take long to find
horror stories
um i mean literally they just come up to
you i don't even have to go look for
them
the other day i'm shooting a commercial
for my um for my ads from for
for running for office makeup ladies
putting stuff on me we're both bored
waiting for them to set everything up so
i'm talking
tell me about you and she goes well i'm
a single mom and i have a 17 year old
son
he is one of the top 25 wrestlers in
california for his weight class
was wrestling six days a week and his
coach was his father figure
the coach begged them not to shut down
the school and and to keep these
want these kids to keep having the
structure they were having
so now the kid is in the home with his
mom cooped up month after month after
month after month
kid because morose becomes sullen he had
enough
integrity and a good enough relationship
with his mom that he went up there and
said mom i feel suicidal
he's now in therapy another person on my
campaign had had a brother living in
oakland had is an
important word he was a football coach
white guy most of all his players are
black coming from fatherless homes
he was their father figure they
practiced six days a week he gave them
structure
begged them not to shut down the school
system these kids need to have structure
two of them got into trouble with the
law one of whom had committed a crime so
serious he's going to be in prison for
years
it would not have had to happen in his
opinion had they had the same structure
that he had before
he got so ticked off he's now in
tennessee resuming his football coaching
career
there not here i read a piece in the la
times a day or two ago about yeah
and uh you know try it with something
like trump acolyte something like that
larry elder's name
and it ends in the most i mean it's the
media is so awful like nothing surprised
me at this point but like the last line
was in effect and there was larry elder
once again defending white people
something to that effect i'm loosely
quoting it
she also she also said larry has been uh
falsely using crime stats about black
people
didn't say what crime stats i was
falsely using and the one she's talking
about is when i told her
that the number one uh cause preventable
death for young white men
is accidents like car accidents drowning
accidents the number one cause of
preventable deaths for young black men
is homicide almost always at the hands
of another young black man
now unless you're prepared to say black
people are just genetically inclined to
commit more
crime you have to ask yourself what the
blank is going on here and the answer is
fatherless homes
there's a direct line between all these
problems we're talking about and kids
coming from homes without a father and
forget about elder i think i gave you
the stat before
obama once said a kid raised a father is
five times more likely to be poor and
commit crime
nine times more likely to drop out of uh
of school and 20 times more likely end
up in in prison
now how have we gone from 25 percent of
black kids being born outside of wedlock
in 1965
to 70 percent now you're telling me that
america's more racist now than it was in
1965
and the answer is the welfare state what
we've done well their answer would be
yes but your answer is
right they would say yes it's because
america kept getting more raises
after obama gets elected and re-elected
kind of a tough argument to make them
but they make that argument
and the fact is we've incentivized women
to marry the government we've allowed
men to abandon their financial and moral
responsibility
that's why we have these problems and
speaking of racism
and you're quite right the democrats are
really pulling out the race card now
because donald trump improved the
percentage of black vote from 8
to 12 from 2016 to 2020 that's a 50
increase and they are scared to death in
27
gallup did a poll obama's running for
the nomination against hillary
and mitt romney's running for the
nomination on the republican side
against john mccain
what percentage of americans gallup
asked would not vote for somebody who's
black
five percent what percentage would not
vote for somebody who's a woman eleven
percent
what percentage would not vote for
somebody who's a mormon twenty-four
percent
what percentage would not vote for
somebody who would be 72 when he became
president
and that'd be john mccain 42 so obama
had a lower hurdle than these what three
white politicians
what are we talking about here grow up
knock it off
there's a there's a sociologist at
harvard he's still there his name is
orlando patterson
back in 1991 he said america
despite its flaws is the least racist
majority white society in the world
provides more opportunities for all for
blacks
than any other country in the world
including all of those of africa
that was 1991 well before obama got
elected
last time i was on cnn i reminded don
lamont
of a of a of a polled study that was
done by time magazine and cnn
of black teens and white teens they
asked them both is racism
a major problem in america both of them
said yes then they asked the follow-up
question to the black teens i never seen
anybody do this before
is racism a big problem a minor problem
or no problem in your own daily life
89 percent of black teens said it was a
minor problem or no problem in my own
daily life in fact
twice as many black teens said quote
failure to take advantage of available
opportunities is a bigger problem than
racism end of quote
that was 23 years ago what are we
talking about here knock it off
knock it off these guys are playing the
race car because they know that they
have to scare
a 13 percent of black people and a bunch
of liberal white people
uh into believing that racism ranged a
major problem because they pulled that
lever for them
95 until donald trump came along and
said what do you have to lose
larry they're scared to death blown me
away once or twice over the years but
are you telling me that the
conservatives
are not racist are you are you telling
me that the conservatives don't hate gay
people
and that the conservatives generally
want to live and let live is that is
that what you're dropping
that's what i'm saying most people want
people to realize their potential
why would it be in anybody's best
interest for a group of people to be
to perceive them as racist how is that
making things better
don't you want everybody to be law
abiding drug abstaining
tax paying people doesn't that make
everything good
and whenever i ask people about systemic
racism i always say
can you can you name names what do you
get david duke after that after that the
list is pretty short isn't it
give me the name who in congress on the
republican side is systemically racist
give me the name
give me the name and sometimes they say
trump are you kidding me
best economy ever under trump he
pardoned jack johnson the first black
heavyweight champion
that obama didn't do despite the fact
that ken burns the lefty
documentarian came to obama and said
please pardon this guy didn't do it
sylvester stallone please pardon the guy
didn't do it trump does it
he also uh commuted the sentence of a
woman named alice johnson who has done a
very very long
trump hotel very long non-violent drug
offense
he put permanent funding of historically
black colleges on
for 10-year footing the one that had
done that before expanded opportunity
zones
dropping some of the rules and
regulations in distressed areas so that
you invite more business if he is a
racist he needs to go back to racism
school
when you were watching the state of the
union and he mentioned lowest black
unemployment of all time and then to
watch the congressional black caucus
right there like this right like to me
that was everything that you've
preached about in your 40 years doing
this how many years you've been on here
at this point
27 27 i gave you an extra 14. but
black don't crack i know i know it looks
really good but but
when you watch that moment it must have
just been like man i have been
screaming about this stuff here's the
guy doing this stuff and they dare sit
there
but it's just one little example they've
been doing this for years uh obama's mom
sent him back from indonesia when he's
10 years old to eventually go to punahou
the finest prep school in the state of
hawaii because she wanted him to have
better education michelle obama did not
go to a
charter school they didn't exist then
but she did not go to her local
government school because it was so bad
she got on the bus and went to a much
better school
ice cube the rapper he didn't go to his
local government school he went to taft
with the time with predominantly white
so what are they telling you they're
telling you they want choice but you
don't get choice
and they're beholden to the teachers
union that adamantly pulls his choice
for all the reasons i just now mentioned
they don't get their automatic dues from
the teachers union
and therefore it threatens them they
couldn't care less about the quality of
education and i mentioned the 300 000
teachers
uh in in in
public school teachers in california and
the average year only 2.2 were fired
imagine i told you between five and
seven percent of them are perceived to
be
incompetent there are twenty thousand
cops here in in uh
in l.a imagine if five percent of them
were bad cops that's a thousand cops on
the streets
we wouldn't put up with it we put up
with fifteen thousand bad teachers
who wants to do something about that we
do they don't if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell